they had an election we they had another
in the last month that they had an
election of a new Prime Minister I know
Boris Johnson okay so you know first I
was okay that was a right thing okay
yeah right at the end yeah all right so
now he has I think it's called prorogue
he has asked the Queen to disband
Parliament and Parliament is has been
disbanded by the Queen for five weeks
and England the left the Labour Party is
all upset they're saying this is
unprecedented it really happens every
year they take about two weeks where the
prime minister says it's Perot and we're
gonna disband so you guys can take care
of the local things we're not going to
talk about national things you could
take care of the things you have to in
your own district cleaner yeah and just
you can be here but we're not meeting on
anything so they do that every year for
they do that every year for one to two
weeks but most I think has ever been
done is four weeks and maybe maybe that
was in World War two he's just done it
for five weeks and the Labour Party
doesn't like it because they're saying
let me guess let me guess he's a fascist
yes yes it was a coup yeah so they're
claiming that it's a coup he says no we
can't get any deal from Europe if we
have Congress cutter I mean Parliament
constantly telling them they need to
understand I'm serious I'm gonna pull us
out of the EU it's the only way they're
gonna offer any kind of deal better than
what we have is if they know I've got a
little bit of a twitchy eye and I just
might do it I think he's right yeah well
look the brexit thing so I so I'm
guessing this is now being framed as
okay so he's a fascist the racists are
all about it well it was for about the
brexit people are the people that
supported regs that are probably
supporting yes this so it's about it was
like that for about a week and then we
moved on to destroy something else yeah
so for a week there it was bad but are
they in the midst of this they're in
week two it just happened like I think
last week you know it's it's it's still
new but it's over
and five weeks are gonna go by hopefully
some of those members of parliament will
have gone back to their districts and
done some of the things that you'd like
them to do like where I live in out in
LA off my exit over here by the Oro 5 I
would love them to clean up there's a
lot of homeless trash is horrible yeah
it's pretty bad here in LA right then
here it was a year ago that I was here
it's already changed this is horrible it
has gotten significantly worse here I
would love to David has actually
contacted our local congressman because
there's a trash compactor Beit it's
basically a dump by our by our exit over
here but I bet you what's gonna happen
is in five weeks some of those guys when
you go back to their districts they're
gonna clean up some stuff and fascism is
not going to arise because some
politicians went back to their districts
to talk to the people they're voting I
mean it's fascism or fascism I think
arise especially it's mostly local yeah
right
fascism I think arises when people feel
like they can't trust anybody and that
the government isn't listening and so
then the government has to use a strong
arm to do things and that's what's
happening now the Labor Party is saying
well that was an old election that voted
for brexit that's not what the people
want today maybe we should have another
election that is what when we had an
election and we voted the Tea Party
members in and they almost all of them
betrayed the American people when we
elected Democrats or Republicans and put
them in the House and the Senate and the
White House and then they still didn't
do anything about Obamacare done that's
why you what that's why a lot of people
say I like Donald Trump he's burning it
all down you know it's interesting
though it's it is both sides on that
because you could even think to Obama's
first - yes he had correct
he had the Senate he had the Congress
that he could have passed Obamacare that
way and he didn't anyway that correctly
after that so they they all they all do
it but I think the bragg's a thing which
I was thinking a lot about the last
couple days because because Faraj was
there it's like if they don't do it now
I know I would have been for it if I
lived there from everything I understand
about brexit because I like you I'm a
small government guy and I would want
the power to be back within my sovereign
nation right yeah and then my local
community yeah but if they don't do it
after the votes
and the revote sand everything and what
does that say to the future of Western
democracy what does that say when when
France has a vote that doesn't go the
way that the powers that be incorrect it
happened what happens here correct it
it's the same story all around the world
now by the way Hong Kong Hong Kong
exporting plastic toys I know not China
Hong Kong yeah the people in the
millions are in the streets they have
been protesting peacefully they took
over the airport for a while they had to
shut it down
Chinese military gathering on the border
they have already sent troops in
yesterday they said that those who are
protesting the end has come
so they're basically protesting China
rule over they there was this really
weird story this guy went over to Taiwan
and he killed his girlfriend they went
on this trip she said hey by the way I'm
pregnant and it's not your child he
freaked out he killed her okay then he
put her in the suitcase then he drove
around Taiwan found a place dumped her
body took her credit card took some
money got on a plane went back to Hong
Kong well by the time he landed in Hong
Kong Taiwanese police found it and went
wait a minute
dead body where's the boyfriend tracked
him back to Hong Kong well Hong Kong
does not have any extradition with with
Taiwan so the guy was getting away with
it
so China said we will extradite him
we'll try him in China well then the
Hong Kong people said whoa whoa whoa
wait we don't want any extradition stuff
because you'll just start scooping
people up off the street that's pretty
fascinating no matter how evil what you
ask Nate went down weird acid our
sovereign yeah and nobody really pays
attention to what really started it yeah
but when you see it was a murder an ugly
grisly murder that started it and now it
is turned into just basic human rights
of we want to be free and China they've
they've in the protests they take these
green lasers
they're doing this to confuse all of the
security cameras because and they're all
wearing masks they look like antiphon
yeah but they're not and they're wearing
masks because all of the cameras are
printing who they are so how is the
media framing this thing you know they
made another statue of the Statue of
Liberty like they did in Tiananmen
Square they in in one of the most
remarkable scenes I have seen in a long
time
they stood together and they were waving
the American flag Wow and they sang our
star-spangled banner they were begging
us to notice them
so Trump I'm sure now is giving the
people of Hong Kong some support right
some at least verbally really mm-hmm
staying out of it he said I hope things
and peacefully we're always for freedom
for all sides but when you look at it
unless you want to get involved and I
don't yeah what do we do were at this
place I wish he was more vocal about it
because that's the way Reagan and Pope
John Paul and Margaret Thatcher
collapsed the Soviet Union is they spoke
that way but at the same time China has
retaliated on our tariffs Trump took our
tariffs up Apple and everybody took it
up another I think it's 25% now horrible
we are now approaching smoot-hawley
record levels of tariffs China said oh
really
we'll do this and they put I don't
remember what it was eighty billion or
some ungodly number we've kind of backed
away from each other here for a minute
but if this isn't solved this is not
good for either of us China just printed
50 trillion dollars of currency 50 the
whole if you stack all the money in the
world up all the cash in the world that
is 60 trillion they just printed 50
trillion and dumped it into half of it
into their economy and half of it into
our wall street so is this thing still
burning this hot right now just happened
in the last couple days yeah it's been
happening
two weeks maybe last week and a half -
what will be interesting I mean this is
I can only comment that from a sort of
you know sky level would be it'll be
interesting to see how the media either
keeps things going or just drops it
altogether because one of the things
that I think all the time is that one of
the the media's biggest failures it's
not just the misreporting and lying and
misquoting and all that it's what they
choose not to cover so then something
happens somewhere in Hong Kong or in
China or in Taiwan or anywhere else
Greenland or Denmark we know nothing
about what their political system is we
know anything about their cultural
system the religious norms any of those
things but then every I'm sure everyone
on Twitter is now an expert in Taiwanese
politics right now we're in Hong Kong no
it's pretty much being with Hong Kong
paid attention to I think it wasn't a
lead story you know with the people I
think people are so sick of of the wars
yeah they were like what are we gonna do
we're gonna do we're gonna take on China
too so I don't think people felt like
there was anything they could do I think
their thoughts and prayers are with the
people of Hong Kong fighting for the
Liberty crew don't you think because for
a guy like you that doesn't want to be
an interventionist but you care about
liberty and you care about into
individual freedoms and all that that
you said you well you'd want Trump maybe
to be a little bit more like Reagan or
Thatcher no just in his speech just
empowering by speech but you can't do it
just by speech because there has to be
something behind it there has to be the
idea that something could be behind it
right so but so it's an odd I find that
to be one of the interesting most
interesting sort of or rich places for
libertarians or Liberty minded people to
debate about things because it's like we
care I think we care the most about
other people being free I want everyone
to be free I don't care what color they
are or what nationality they are
anything I thought it's not enough just
to say but it's not enough just to say
and then on the other hand do you then
want to use force no so because it
becomes this no it doesn't it what we've
lost is our ability to believe in
ourself
[Music]